what to carry on the name you think it's
going to be a boy yeah she was just the
backbone of the family
she was always there for all of us
Maureen nottage loved life but at the
beginning of April 2020 she died alone
in a care home she had covered Maureen's
daughter Kim says she's angry that the
then Health secretary Matt Hancock
appears to have ignored expert advice
that could have led to care home
residents being protected more so to
have free tests for you know over a
hundred people and not knowing and you
know it was it's this we had the
postcode Lottery comes into effect
and you know they they said that they
took done the test on mum but never even
found up to inform the family that
that's what they was doing so we had no
idea that she was that unwell there'd
already been about 10 deaths in that
care home and nobody knows what that was
for and people were just being
discharged back from hospitals into that
care home
in early April as we reported at the
time corbid was spreading fast through
Care Homes they were ill-equipped to
cope the NHS was often being prioritized
for supplies of PPE and testing kits
many Care Homes like this one in
Scarborough decided to lock down much
earlier than the government first
advised but in so many cases it wouldn't
be enough without aprons without masks
without testing the virus would be
allowed to spread
and in so many cases the consequences
were catastrophic
at the time we put the concerns of care
home owners to the health secretary Matt
Hancock
the care sector is watching this right
now and is desperate for you to tell
them that they will get regular tests so
they can end this Lottery can you give
that guarantee to them yes I can Nick
that is coming so to my mind
um if you cast your mind back to to
April 2020 it was all about testing
and the NHS and PPE
um have a local presence Mike padgum
owns Five care homes in North Yorkshire
and has been in the care industry for 30
years he thinks the decision not to test
everyone entering Homes at that time was
a crucial mistake we're looking at these
WhatsApp messages how does it make you
feel knowing what you know now well when
I saw the messages that have been
reported I was quite shocked really
because as a layperson which I call
myself is that if um tests could only be
done being discharged from hospital into
Care Homes then surely the community
should also have been a priority because
a lot of the issues were the virus
coming in by members of the community
and even staff so to my mind it should
have been both
decisions made in these early often
chaotic days of the pandemic will of
course be poured over by the independent
inquiry the question is were these sound
judgments under pressure or costly
mistakes Nick Martin Sky News
Scarborough
about